John Wayne's worst movie wasn't just
panned by critics it gave half its
production crew cancer films can impact
our lives for better or worse but these
brought about total ruin released in
1960 the Alamo was a passion project for
John Wayne marking the movie stars
directorial debut unfortunately the
production was beset with all sorts of
problems one of the lead actors broke
his foot a flood wiped out the set and
about 80% of the crew came down with a
nasty bug but in between dealing with
outof control fires and automobile
accidents the cast and crew of The Alamo
found themselves in the middle of a
murder investigation it all started when
a group of actors known as the Hollywood
Starlight players auditioned for the
film they were all cast as extras except
for one actress named leene ethd she was
given a much larger role complete with
actual lines and as a result she got to
live closer to the set however this
didn't sit well with her actor boyfriend
Chester Harvey Smith who had to get a
room in a town 20 M away angry about the
living arrangements Smith demanded that
Ethridge move into town with him and
when she refused Smith responded by
stabbing her to death with a 12in knife
Smith was quickly arrested and Wayne
later said he thought Smith should
receive the death penalty instead the
actor was sentenced to 30 years behind
bars based on the novel by James Dicky
Deliverance is a powerful story about
how people react when they're ripped
from civilization and thrust into a
world without law or order unfortunately
most people remember it simply as the
movie where Ned batty gets sexually
assaulted by a hillbilly granted it is
the most memorable moment in a film full
of Toothless woodsmen and decrepit
rednecks in other words it's easy to
understand why the folks of Raben County
have mixed feelings about this film
Raben County if you don't know is where
Deliverance was filmed and believe it or
not the movie did wonders for the local
economy according to a 2012 CNN article
tourists bring over $40 million to the
area each year however while the money
is nice not everyone is happy with the
way Southerners are depicted in the film
speaking with CNN one Raven County
resident said there are still a lot of
people here locally who have hard
feelings about the stereotypes the movie
represented but this goes a whole lot
further than just hurt feelings
according to a report by Marketplace
people have claimed they were passed
over for jobs just because they came
from Ren County and when locals planned
on celebrating the film's 40th
anniversary quite a few citizens
complained don't have a do nothing like
this
again don't come back up here a genius
and online activist who helped create
RSS Reddit and creative comments Aaron
Schwartz thought it was wrong to charge
astronomic fees for scientific research
and scholarly Works wanting to make a
point swar hacked into the digital
library J store and illegally downloaded
quite a few articles but this stunt
didn't sit well with the feds and soon
Schwartz found himself facing 35 years
behind bars as a result the internet
Pioneer ended his own life at the age of
26 so what does this have to do with the
movies well the law used to prosecute
Schwartz was directly connected to the
1983 hit war games this Matthew brck
movie follows a young computer wiz who
hacks into NORAD and accidentally almost
starts World War II evidently the movie
freaked out the folks in Washington DC
with one Congressional report claiming
War Games was a quote realistic
representation of what hackers could do
would you like to see some projected
kill ratios while it wasn't the only
Factor war games played a very real part
in inspiring the Computer Fraud and
Abuse Act of 1984 originally the law was
meant to prosecute people who attacked
Banks or agencies related to America's
defense system but over the years the
law was amended so many times that it
could be used to prosecute hackers who
steal government secrets as well as
hackers who download scholarly articles
there have been quite a few biopics in
recent years that have left their
subjects feeling rather unhappy that
includes former NFL player Michael or
who has claimed that The Blind Side
severely impaired his professional
career in the film or is portrayed as a
troubled teen who finds New Direction in
life when he meets Leanne Tui a wealthy
mom played by Sandra bullet over the
course of the film Tui inspired or to
play football and go to college and he
ultimately joined the NFL but while the
movie earned more than $300 million and
snagged Bullock and Oscar it didn't do
or any favors speaking to SB Nation in
2016 or explained his feelings about the
movie saying there was a time in my life
early in my NFL career where the movie
just seemed to take away from me it made
it seem like the movie was responsible
for my NFL career not my play not my
hard work you have to understand before
I moved moved in with the family I was
an All-American things only became more
complicated in 2023 when or sued the Tui
family revealing that they had never
actually adopted him and claiming that a
conservatorship they had tricked him
into was used to financially manipulate
him even early in his career Leonardo
DiCaprio always preferred lending his
talents to movies with dark subject
matter sometimes this resulted in
critical Acclaim while other times it
led to movies like The Basketball
Diaries the movie follows Di Caprio
playing celebrated author and poet Jim
Carol as a teenager in high school
struggling with drug addiction it leads
him to slowly isolate himself from
everything and everyone he cares about
until he finally gets clean after a
six-month stint in prison normally a
film like this would have long left the
Zeitgeist more than 25 years after its
release however the movie later became
entangled in an unimaginable tragedy at
Heath High School in West Paduka
Kentucky on December 1st 1997 Michael
carel entered the school premises with
four concealed firearms and proceeded to
fire 11 shots in the school Lobby this
tragically led to three students losing
their lives and five more being injured
carel later claimed to have been
inspired by a dream sequence in The
Basketball Diaries where Jim dreamed of
shooting his class this led to a lawsuit
against the movie's Distributors that
ultimately got dismissed the Conqueror a
1956 film is notorious for being
associated with one of the biggest onset
tragedies in Hollywood history the movie
is poorly regarded among film fans and
considered a run-of-the-mill origin
story for genas Khan with John Wayne
woefully miscast in the lead role the
plot revolves around Khan kidnapping
borai a royal of the totters which leads
to war despite his lack of leadership
skills KH ultimately wins both the war
and the girl unsurprisingly the film
received dismal reviews from critics
however the movie's quality isn't even
the most significant tragedy associated
with it the atomic energy commission had
assured the film's producers that the
shooting location in the Utah desert was
safe unfortunately the area was located
less than 140 mi downwind from a major
Nevada desert nuclear test site almost
half of the 220 cast and crew members
involved in the film developed some form
of cancer later in life according to a
1980 report from people at that time 46
people who worked on the film had died
from the disease which was likely
connected Ed in some part to their
participation in the production The
Matrix is a film with many meanings and
interpretations the wowski have said
that they originally envisioned the film
as a trans allegory with an early script
even featuring characters having
different genders in the virtual world
and the real world it's also a story
about the dangers of technology and what
it truly means to be human however the
film's complexity also laid the
groundwork for some severe
misinterpretations i' only tried to
realize the truth
what truth there is no spoon one
particularly troubling impact of the
Matrix is how some individuals started
using its premise of humans living in a
computer generated world to justify
their crimes This legal defense strategy
became known as The Matrix defense the
first known use of this defense came in
2000 when a Swiss exchange student
killed and mutilated his land lady in
San Francisco according to the Boston
Globe the students cited evil Vibes as
his reasoning and said he was scared of
getting quote sucked into the Matrix he
was subsequently ruled insane there have
been several other cases attempting to
use the same defense including that of
Lee Malvo the so-called DC sniper in a
later report CNN noted that this defense
strategy is no longer as reliable and a
defendant attempting to use it would
likely lose their case in the present
day taxi driver is a mustsee for movie
enthusiasts it follows the story of
Travis Bickle a New York City cabbie who
gradually loses touch with reality and
resorts to extreme violence leading to a
bloody climax Taxi Driver quickly became
a hit earning a great box office return
for its budget and receiving numerous
accolades including an Oscar nod for a
young jod Foster for best supporting
actress as chronicled by the independent
the film's success led to John Hinkley
Jr becoming obsessed with Foster he
repeatedly approached her and stalked
her and when she politely rejected his
advances he felt compelled to find a way
to impress her Hinkley Jr had reportedly
watched Taxi Driver over a dozen times
and was inspired by a scene in which
Bickle tries to shoot a politi
consequently Pinkley Jr attempted to
assassinate President Ronald Reagan
firing a bullet that narrowly missed his
heart I had the delusion back in 1981
that by shooting the president I could
impress Jody Foster he was subsequently
placed under psychiatric confinement The
Birth of a Nation undeniably stands as
one of the most racist films of all time
the movie Chronicles of post Civil War
America in which confederate Colonel Ben
Cameron establishes the klex clan and
terrorizes black Americans in the South
all while being positioned as a hero by
the script the film is often credited
with pioneering cinematic techniques
that continue to be used in film making
today such as close-ups however fixating
solely on the film's technical prowess
obscures the fact that it played a
significant role in revitalizing the
Klux Clan it's glor hor ification of
lynchings and cross burnings quickly
turned the film into a recruitment tool
for the clan making its Legacy truly
evil when the film was initially
released the NAACP rightly raised
objections about its extensive use of
blackface and the Despicable portrayal
of black people however these objections
did not prevent the movie from becoming
one of the most commercially successful
films of all time a Harvard University
study even revealed that the film's
initial Road Show release led to an
increase in and lynchings by up to five
times in areas where it was screened
this Grim reality solidifies The Birth
of a Nation as one of the most harmful
movies ever made Stanley kubri one of
the most revered directors of all time
is best known for his exploration of the
darker aspects of human nature
particularly violence of all his films
none delves into violence quite Like A
Clockwork Orange the movie follows Alex
delarge a violent gang leader in a near
future Britain who Dawn a white costume
assum bowler hat spending his days
assaulting the unhoused and terrorizing
people in home invasions with his gang
the film's underlying message is that
human beings have not entirely evolved
Beyond such violent and aggressive
tendencies we've merely hidden those
behaviors beneath a facade of
civilization however at the time of its
release some critics argued that the
movie ended up glorifying violence A
Clockwork Orange stirred so much
controversy that kuri himself asked
Warner Brothers to withdraw the film
from Cinemas reports of CopyCat violent
attacks inspired by the movie one of the
most notorious individuals influenced by
the film was Peter Foster a British
Fairground worker who became obsessed
with it Foster often dressed like Alex
delarge and subjected multiple partners
to Violent abuse over the course of
three decades killing two women he was
ultimately convicted and handed multiple
life sentences in
[Music]
prison